nuestro mundo está fuera de la ordinario
eso todos lo sabemos algunas personas la
mayoría está correctamente para otras
como yo lo está incorrectamente por qué
porque conceptos básicos conceptos que
vemos día a día están mal están
incorrectos
son cosas que deberían de cambiar como
cual es un ejemplo muy cual un ejemplo
muy claro sobre esto es el dinero el
dinero para algunas personas es una
necesidad es algo muy importante en
salud para mí es solo un papel un papel
que al ponerle valor nosotros como
sociedad lo nos estamos quitando para mí
algo extraordinario de la buena forma
sería que nos respetáramos como por los
valores que tenemos no por una cantidad
que va y viene
el ejemplo que más me causa algo que se
me hace muy importante es que uno
- capaz que una vez que un adulto porque
porque la mayoría dice que con la edad
vienen las experiencias tienen el
aprendizaje para mí no para mí no
importa si tengas 19 años
15 21 ó 50 para mí no me importa a mí no
me importa eso porque simplemente las
experiencias no vienen con la edad o si
bien en la con la edad las vivimos
diferentes algunas personas logran sacar
algo positivo de ellas y otras personas
logran sacar algo negativa cómo es esto
desgraciadamente tuve una experiencia no
tan agradable con un adulto
estaba platicando acerca de la escuela
sobre mi generación sobre que veía
importante y extraordinario en algunas
personas
es adulto me dijo que básicamente era
muy dramática y que todavía no tenía la
edad para entender todo esto y que las
hormonas están haciendo algo no lo
típico
al principio dije pues si tiene razón no
tengo el mismo aprendizaje no tengo las
mismas experiencias pero hubo un punto
en el que dije no esto no puede ser
posible porque porque yo he vivido cosas
diferentes he aprendido totalmente de
personas que me ha influido de una forma
correcta en mí esta persona se cree
inferior a adolescentes oa niños este
adulto mayor más maduro se cree mejor
que yo porque por las experiencias
pero en el punto en el que yo creo que
te crees mejor que otra persona te estás
volviendo inferior porque todas las
personas somos iguales tenemos los
mismos derechos y podemos hacer
literalmente lo mismo cada quien decide
cómo tomarlo esta experiencia la toma de
una forma positiva quiero influir en
cada uno de ustedes algunas personas
efectivamente no lo notan así
y pues yo creo que lo también de otra
manera adultos aquí presentes levanten
la mano
pues todos los que levantaron la mano
quiero que se lleven algo de esto
escuchen a sobrinos a sus hijos escuchen
los que se sienten escuchados que puedan
hablar con ustedes libremente y que no
tengan miedo a hablarles de lo que sea
porque porque al ustedes darles esa
confianza no sólo van a tener confianza
con ustedes sino a hablarle al mundo en
general también es cuando cuando sepan
que ya hicieron esa parte de ese trabajo
cuando les hablen cuando confíen en
ustedes sabrán que habrán hecho algo
increíble algo extraordinario
[Aplausos]